when do you think you will retire that's  a good question because i am already  retired and to me retirement just means  not doing things you don't want to do  so the only things that i have to do  that i don't want to do are basically  taxes and government related things  other than that i control my time  and i don't sacrifice today for an  imagine tomorrow  and so if you can get into a job that  you like where you are tracked in your  outputs rather than your inputs you'll  be able to control your time much better  and once you can control your time you  can allocate your time such that  you're not wasting it  and you can live most of your days not  100 but most of your days as to what you  want to do and then you're essentially  retired  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  you